seit einem jahr will ich im video machen
indem ich versuche surfen zu lernen aber
die leute wohnortes kate wäre ich aber
in den letzten wochen konnte dann
endlich wieder eine der wenigen stehende
wellen in deutschland aufmachen grüße am
12 langenfeld bei denen ich das ganze
machen durfte die mich an einem der
ersten tage der saison haben surfen
lassen dadurch hat man die möglichkeit
das surfen in deutschland auszuprobieren
man muss nicht an den atlantik fahren
man muss nicht ins ausland fahren max
und ich haben uns wieder mal auf grüner
testen lassen sind nach langenfeld
gefahren und haben das ganze ausprobiert
mehrere super leistungsstarke pumpen
drücken hier unmengen an wasser aus dem
see hoch und beschleunigen das so dass
eine welle entstehen kann
dadurch hat man natürlich auch
verschiedene einstellungsmöglichkeiten
kann bestimmen wie viel wasser
durchgedrückt wird wie schnell das
wasser durch gedrückt wird und kann die
welle so den verschiedenen können
ständen anpassen das ist so eine
ordentliche wassermassen hier hinter mir
läuft schon die stehende welle die haben
wir gerade schon in betrieb genommen die
bauzeit jetzt immer weiter auch ist sehr
beeindruckend wie viel wasser hier jetzt
schon schon am fließen ist ich kann
überhaupt nicht einschätzen ob das was
wird oder nicht ich hoffe jetzt direkt
in meinen neoprenanzug und dann geht es
glaube ich schon mit der einweisung los
ich bin sehr gespannt und auch ein
bisschen beängstigend geiles wetter
das wasser hat so ungefähr sieben bis
acht grad also es ist schon wirklich
noch kalt deswegen habe ich mir gerade
eben noch neopren schuhe und handschuhe
besorgt damit ich das alles ein bisschen
länger als nur fünf minuten durchhalten
bin sehr gespannt mein erster
wasserkontakt dieses jahr nachdem ich
letztes jahr im november ja dieses
eisbaden video gemacht hatte
gary aus wie wasser macht wie schnell
das läuft
wir haben insgesamt eine stunde zeit
also es ist kein sieben tage projektes
ist kein eintages projekt ist eigentlich
ein stunden projekt in einer stunde
führten lernt ja was die sache
ich einfacher macht auch kopf mäßig am
liebsten hätte ich das ganze natürlich
auch sieben tage probiert aber das ist
eine riesen maschine super aufwendig da
muss eine person dabei seien die
aufpasst und die dafür ausgebildet ist
das geht also nicht wir mussten uns
dieses mal auf eine stunde beschränkt
ich habe mir schon überlegt dass hier
einen zweiten teil machen will wo ich
das ganze im atlantik ausprobiere sobald
das krone messfeld wieder möglich ist
muss ein profi und ausgebildeter trainer
auf dieser welle hat probiert mir in
möglichst kurzer zeit möglichst viel
theorie wissen mit zu geben so dass sich
grob weiß wie das ganze funktioniert
gewichtsverteilung des mit mehr druck
auf dem hinteren reihen ausgemacht die
pocken wäre drücke aufs hintere bein
blickrichtung ist beschiss gruber zum
langenfeld logo okay das wasser völlig
weise die sehr laut und nicht nur über
ziemlich okay wir sind dann aber relativ
schnell an die welle gegangen weil ich
glaube das funktioniert besser in tritt
das auszuprobieren und dann zu merken
was falsch macht sieht so ein bisschen
wasser
an den polen fuß und der christlichen
klosters metten
auch ein stück weit hinten rechts
jetzt selbst mit der linken hand vorne
fest was hinten ins wasser legen und den
hinteren fuß aus patch denn dann stellst
du den vorderen fuß aus pet und einfach
runter drücken und fuß und ist schon
richtig druck aufs brett und jetzt
schaust du über zum logo schlimmste nach
vorne und jetzt nach vorne lehnen
natürlich war ich extrem um sicher keine
frage und das board hatte wahrscheinlich
mehr kontrolle über mich als ich über
das board aber ich stand
zu unserer verwunderung hat tatsächlich
beim aller ersten mal geklappt und ich
stand das ist komplett verrückt klar ich
habe in meinem leben schon viel auf
verschiedenen brettern gestanden
ski snowboard skateboard das habe ich
alles schon viele tage in meinem leben
lang gemacht aber es ist trotzdem sehr
anderes gefühl und es hat mich sehr
überrascht dass es so gut funktioniert
hat
sie zu mir bei mir lernen die zu
eröffnen ersten welle
ich habe das ganze sogar schon mal im
atlantik ausprobiert das ganze aber eher
schlecht als recht und ich habe relativ
schnell die motivation verloren und dann
irgendwann angefangen auf dem
campingplatz einfach irgendwelche
youtube videos zu drehen wo ich nicht
selbst tätowierer oder so das ganze war
wenig erfolgreich also ich habe offen
surfbrett stehend jetzt relativ wenig
erfahrung außerdem habe ich relativ
schnell gemerkt dass es wirklich sehr
kalt war und das sollte mir zum ende hin
auch noch zum verhängnis werden versucht
zwei waren schneller vorbei als er
angefangen
ich habe ich dinge selber zu viel
vertrauen versuche drei war dann
deutlich besser als alles zuvor ich
konnte ziemlich sicher mich von der
einen zur anderen seite bewegen was eine
vorübung ist für die eigentliche
bewegung auf der welle auf der man so
auf und ab während aber jetzt geht's
richtig los jetzt muss ich
jetzt geht es richtig wir haben die
bälle dann ziemlich schnell verstellt
ein bisschen steiler und schneller
gemacht um ein bisschen mehr
bewegungsspielraum zu haben das hat man
auf jeden fall deutlich gemerkt die
welle ist lauter geworden um deutlich
brachialem mehr muss man sich den wellen
anpassen hier passt man die welle
einfach auf die person an komplett
verrückt dass so etwas möglich ist
zu wenig nach ja ich habe gerade so
gesagt so jetzt wo wir hoffentlich fällt
der film du hast ja ich vertrau mir
selber direkt zu viel da ja lass dir
zeit schauen dass wir schreiben hier
steht das ist wichtig sondern auch sehr
stabil steht es auf der position haben
alles kannst du nicht überhören jeder
stürzen
das hier ist doch ein bisschen arbeit
das war schon wirklich ein krasses
erfolgserlebnis und genau zu dem
zeitpunkt hat aber mein körper
angefangen wirklich nachzulassen also es
war wirklich unendlich anstrengen ich
habe auf jeden fall deutlich gemerkt
dass mir super viel kondition und auch
einfach kraft fehlt meine beine sind
nach zehn sekunden auf der welle
komplett schlapp und über meine arme
nach drei partien müssen erst ganz
außerdem wurde mir mit jedem
wasserkontakt deutlich kälter mein
gesicht hat angefangen sich zu verfärben
und das hat sich dann auch alles in
meiner performance wieder gespielt
ich hoffe ihr könnt überhaupt
distributeure leute
sehr sehr krank
gallen ist schon sehr anstrengend aber
auch nach der dritten nach dem dritten
mal hin und her
vor allem frauen das standbein glaube
ich dass das privileg hatte komplett
alleine auf der welt zu sein hatte ich
halt keine richtigen pausen weil
irgendwie gerade andere leute am surfen
war sondern ich bin wirklich rein raus
rein raus um nach dem fünften oder
sechsten versuch habe ich das deutlich
genähert
pocking anstrengend und die ganze zeit
rein raus rein raus die sind ausdauer
muss man mitbringen
hier habe ich mich auf meinen beinen
ich bin so mag dann ist aber vielleicht
auch smaato für weitermachen wenn wir
durch diese sekunde
ich hatte zwar das gefühl die basics
verstanden zu haben und die auch
ziemlich sicher auf der welle machen zu
können aber alles was darüber hinausging
war einfach aussichtslos ich habe es
einfach nicht hinbekommt der
ernüchternde ist nicht zu verstehen was
man falsch machen
also ich mir wird gesagt was ich falsch
mache ich kam das kann das auch
verstehen aber ich kann es halt nicht
umsetzen nicht so wie bei häufig bei
sachen dass ich so das gefühl okay sie
das habe ich gemacht höchst für drehe
ich dann läuft's besser sondern ihr euch
das gefühl dass die welle mich
kontrolliert und ich nicht die welle
ja ja und das ist nicht so optimal
aber sieht gut aus fürs erste mal und
kommentiert
vielleicht werden wir sehen die das
aussieht wenn man es wirklich kann
welchen weg ich noch vor mir habe um
dahin zu kommen
hier ist jetzt noch 23 mal aber mein
körper sagt wirklich macht zu all das
hat mich lange nicht mehr so angestrengt
ja
stern
das höchste gericht
es war cool ich bin trotzdem froh dass
es für heute vorbei ist kann sehr zu
schaffen
nein weiß nicht ob mir jemals so kalt
war eine welle gliedmaßen sind so kalt
ich kann nicht vernünftig reden
resources war unendlich anstrengen tolle
neuer hat super funktioniert ich konnte
auf der welle stehen ich konnte ein
bisschen auf und ab fahren auch wenn ich
jetzt in dieser stunde nicht perfekt
surfen gelernt habe war dass ein voller
erfolg nur ein zweites video werde ich
richtung atlantik an wenn ihr bock
darauf habt das sehen wollt last dem
video gerne leichter vergesst nicht den
kanal zu abonnieren damit die kein video
nach verfasst vielen dank an zwölf
langenfeld jacky aus wenn ihr selber
ausprobieren wollt und wir sehen uns
nächste woche